we're broke like nearly every state
across the country we don't have any
more money Wisconsin is fine Wisconsin
is great actually we're broke America's
broke America is not Luke so which is it
are we broke or are we fine you know
it's a little late to quibble over
semantics but the plain fact is when it
comes to public finances at all levels
of government work here's deficit
projections from the president's own
proposed 2012 budget he predicts that
the red ink will continue to flow for as
long as he may be in office at the state
level we're looking at a combined 125
billion dollar shortfall between what
States expect to spend versus what they
expect to raise in revenue for 2012
alone and at the local level the
National League of Cities is estimating
revenue shortfalls between 2010 and 2012
will end up totaling somewhere between
56 billion dollars and eighty three
billion dollars we have to confront the
fact that our government spends more
than it takes in that is not sustainable
call us bro call us fine but our
problems aren't going to get better by
pretending they don't exist unless you
think your elected officials have tiger
blood coursing through their veins like
Charlie Sheen i cured it with my brain
with my mind all the hard work is still
ahead of us for reason TV i'm nick
gillespie
you